I don't do my own estate planning estate
planning is too complicated I might miss
something it might cost me a lot of
money I don't work on my own cars
anymore
you pop out pop up in the hood you need
a dadgum computer to work on a car back
in the day I could turn a wrench but I
might spend like five thousand hours
under that hood and still not have any
idea what was wrong with that car I
don't do that anymore there's a lot of
things I don't pull my own teeth I mean
I'm not that I lose that me teeth but
but I pull my own teeth I don't film on
teeth I don't even clean my own teeth
except with the toothbrush daily I mean
we're good you know you have a hygienist
to do this right so there's a lot of
stuff in our culture today we don't do
ourselves I know there's a DIY movement
and a lot of things but Texas is not one
of them the average person spends 13
hours doing their taxes it's your time
not worth anything and on top of that
when you get them done you're dead it
wrong most of the time you lose money
because you didn't know what you were
doing you know how many pages there are
in the tax code that you're supposed to
know in order for you to fill out your
own taxes now listen get a tax Pro use a
mechanic get you a dentist and get you
an estate planner I mean get a tax
professional go to Dave Ramsey calm
click on the ELP let someone else that
knows how to do this they can do it in a
1:1 Julianne Thor the time you can oh
and by the way it'll be right then every
person doing their own taxes with
software gets back 800 dollars less than
they should have that's a pretty
expensive mistake not to mention the
fact you spent 13 hours of your own time
on average messing this up so get a tax
pro it's pretty simple the lp for taxes
endorsed local provider for taxes in
your area that's what you're looking for
you can you find them at Dave Ramsey
comm they'll help you out it's silly to
do this yourself really silly
you